hello everyone
scp-049 year playing clay ink once again
today we're going to be playing the
nanovirus a very fast-paced planck
cytochrome search and genetic mimic will
make this game-mode a little easier
because that experience players are
plaguing now the nanovirus cure starts
from the word go start location will be
Saudi Arabia as you can see the Cure is
already at 1%
this is not good I'm going to be playing
with the game speed a lot of this one
because things have to be done that I
was taste it's only on paranoia but just
to increase the infectivity a little bit
at the start whilst not sacrificing a
lot of disease points yeah code fragment
interception not yet there we go
15 disease points to be saved
okay
it is quite a slow play to start off but
things have to be done in such a quick
manner that I have to play with speed
quite a bit on this as I am quite
impatient and don't like to sit at the
base speed the entire time there are two
as you will see the cure is a 50% of
this point I think they'll need to wait
before I had baked the Cure more I would
say 95 just to give myself as much time
as possible without risking losing the
game if the k-19 is these points I need
18 for water too I am of course aiming
for bio aerosol for maximum infectivity
yes I know game I do not need your help
for such matters I'm an expert
full points sound here we go mortar to
now 85 on the cure at this point it's
getting dangerous opposed to using the
natural ability of the nanovirus so now
that I've got extreme bio aerosol my
infectivity will be quite decent percent
timing at this point is crucial son
normal speed must be used okay so
radical elements established will bring
the Cure back down to 55% I also need to
save up points to slow it down some drug
resistance and genetic hardly are on my
priority list at this point
I still have one radical oh that's
established to use so even at this point
things seem to be runnin like smoothly
there was a lot of infection lines
coming from Saudi Arabia which is always
good to see New Zealand is infected by
the gas car is affecting c-cold
resistance is always a must at this
point is agreement
just need to save up cold resistance
it's relatively cheap so it won't be
that hard
resistance to brutal difficulty is
always essential for quick infectivity
in the stage of the game
[Music]
27 disease points multiplied with now
okay as you can see the cure is reaching
critical mass again almost 85% this is
quite dangerous so I'm just buying minor
symptoms to increase the infectivity
let's see
apologies further like a chitchat and
this let's play a ring you have to focus
but it does seem to be paying off as
there is a lot of infectivity going on
at this point I always have to keep an
eye on the Cure because it gets cured
that is game over lots of bubbles to dig
Bob this is always go down gives me
plenty of ammunition to kill the
population at a later date my ski
particularly usable really is a pain in
the posterior
Oh bum escalator would say trophy
community is the best possible immunity
you can have in the first world
countries I've accumulated a lot of
disease points in this stage and six so
so then it comes to the stage where I
hit the kill switch of diseases so to
speak it will go very fast assuming I
don't get cured in that space of time 70
percent seems to be going considerably
slower this is a good
[Music]
I think I should get a little bit more
because some infections are kicking into
overdrive especially in Africa Canada
Greenland seems to be infected quite
basically at this point so it's just a
matter of time good
Ukraine allows to be infected for some
for some reason why quite sure so
hemorrhagic shock tell hemorrhaging I
think at this point genetic reshuffle
will just give me that extra time
to spread it I think all the world
should be infected quite soon I loved it
there all of a sudden no healthy people
left in the world
The Killers at 70 this is looking quite
good 30 40 disease points are spiking up
as people die and at this point it's
just a matter of time
hitting the cure vials still I doubt it
won't make any difference even if I
didn't hit them and at this point is
just a waiting game they failed to kill
my Nana virus so they perished hopefully
in a very painful way so that is how you
destroy the world with a nanovirus I
hope this has been an educational I hope
to see you again next time
and as always I am the cure
you